[Music]
hey
these are the codes of the furries okay
welcome back to the break room everybody
i'm cuddle this is tussle
ah
this is a daily show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know um joining me live from the new
rock stars break room in our los angeles
offices i've got mr brandon bear oh
hello happy to be here the wonderful
jessica clemons team jinx all the way
jonathan
and uh the ever present mr tommy bechdel
counting down those days till friday
friday will be comic con uh the the much
rumored much debated never forgotten
camera four real quick just get out
into something else camera three
don't let the fat cats at new rock stars
tell you thomas that's not gonna happen
throw up
throw up molina which is what i call him
whoa
he's gonna try and cancel comic-con and
turn it into a push-up contest
turns out
he can't do that legally comic-con has
been registered trademark it's a piece
of mind you tell phillip that he can
empty
instead of filling up
his promises eggplant's in the chat for
tomicon everybody okay
um uh speaking of eggplants
uh
we've got a very cool
no
sorry sorry girl
we've got a very cool redemption today
okay every time we hit a hundred dollars
in super chats which we appreciate
everybody's generosity throwing out
those doubloons to help us bring this
show to you every time we hit 100 bucks
one of these numbered buckets
okay each of these contains a secret
prize and this is true
three of the four of us have no idea
what's in any of these bus trips i don't
know what's in the barn okay four of the
four of us have no idea what's in the
buckets here they um
uh we truly don't uh and one of these is
gonna get punched and reveal whatever is
inside i assume it's like a cool fun
thing but they could also be terrible
things poisonous spiders we have no idea
uh and only when we hit uh multiples of
100 well these get opened okay our
eggplants will block out the sun that we
will munch in the shade
sorry chrissy
crazy calling out the eggplant brigade
it's like i'm in a call of duty lobby
chrissy
oh no
oh i'm sorry uh okay uh also quick
reminder the break room is now on tick
tock follow us on tick tock at the
underscore break room there's some
really fun content on there but
we got to move on to headlines
uh a lot of today's episode we're gonna
be talking about phase six those
incredible
uh somewhat mysterious
marvel announcements from the weekend
about their phase six uh but first we
want to talk about some phase four and
five news uh it's coming up we got word
uh about uh news coming out about black
panther wakanda forever uh that atlantis
home of namor
is going to be renamed to lokon
telokayan i like
i'm not very good at pronouncing
anything
much less words that uh derived from
other languages but that is a um
a place from
uh perhaps a theory do we believe
although i i like pulling on real actual
civilizations to create these these uh
fictional marvel ones is disney
planning a little more animation
atlantis movies and want to avoid
confusion by well like i mean
like atlantis is an existing franchise
in the disney catalog yeah i think
there's that i think it's also
separating it from like aquaman sure and
like that concept that's a great point
that's that's probably more reasonable
and i think this is smart because it
does help tie in a lot of the where
they've been going with phase four
eternals and what we learned in moon
night and like tying all that together
you know and even with like thor 11
thunder where the importance of gods
like having this all kind of tied
together yeah i i always
i just really dig it
because like
they're breaking from the comics yeah
yeah we don't know why like what they're
gonna do with it and that could totally
be brian coogler and the creative team
behind this movie can do whatever they
want to tell the best story possible
right like they're not beholden to stick
with the kind of classic comics canon i
think that's really cool um speaking of
what kind of forever composer ludwig
gorinson who did the awesome score for
the first black panther movie revealed
we began to build a musical vocabulary
for the characters storylines and
cultures of talokan and wakanda
very cool so maybe we'll get like fun
themes for the different locations kind
of contrasting comparing there um is
kendrick lamar going to be the wakanda
part of the telocon
oh i'll play both
um can't get enough kendrick um uh we're
gonna talk about this a little later but
uh there is some news
about um directors for phase six
uh though as of now
no director announced for avengers
secret wars
long time speculation uh about who that
might be if there's somebody already
lined up but kevin feige said in an
interview no we do not have a director
for secret wars and you will see about
some of the other director announcements
at some point he said this during comic
con we got one of those announcements
this morning we'll talk about that in a
moment but uh still no director
announced for secret wars
um though speaking of wars and marvel
armor wars show runner yasser lesser
i say all right yes yes okay thank you
tommy dummy has personally met this
person thus he is the
official
as they say if you do five minutes of
stand up out of night where someone does
30 minutes you're basically comedic
equals
so yes sir call me
oh boy we're over a hundred yay oh
whoa
bobby shattuck my man
johnson can you run a pull on one two
three and four and the chat will get to
vote on which one we break open and we
can choose which one of us wants to
bring you yeah i think you did all the
hard work you want i don't want to go
first again uh i think it should be one
of you real quick pick what do you think
might be in one of these buckets earlier
you had speculated about wet spaghetti
yeah i think it's maybe dry
dried cookies are they gross things the
spaghetti has been cooked but it's
drying oh i think there's gonna be like
a marvel toy
oh well you packed them right no oh you
did
no
oh
sam
didn't
to okay so you might be loosely familiar
with things that could be in there but
you don't know what's in anybody or
anything like that okay and i'm not to
be fair i only bought a couple of things
i had sam get the rest ooh sorry i have
one as a gift card to islands fine craft
burgers yes
not a sponsor of the show but they hold
a place in all of our hearts a sponsor
of my emotional eating
we'll get to that later
i want a similar vibe but more immediate
i want candy on one of these and i will
consume whatever is in there it is sam
and sam sam's the person our greatest
person in the office that draws all the
designs for the whiteboard she's very
creative uh very artistic and i feel
like i could see her putting some crazy
weird things in she know she did she did
ask me earlier like what do we do with
all those ants we've done right now no
sam is possibly the kindest person that
works in new rochester i don't want to
budget now i'm too scared i just can't
chill this way first no and i can't
believe what oh
i'll go first while we wait for the poll
um to pick which bucket we're gonna open
up thank you for everybody that's been
super chatting uh back to yeah yasser
lester
he confirmed that armor wars is still
happening it was absent from all those
announcements those announcements that
went all the way like almost four years
from the future no mention of
armor wars so we don't know maybe
there's just up in the air about when it
won't release i like that the show
runner had to be the one to be like it's
still happening i hope the other shows
that weren't mentioned also on there are
like no my show was also still happening
like just because they didn't say it
doesn't mean it's not happening they
might and they also might have let him
have that like they're like this is like
you go like feige might have been like
go ahead and announce that it's still
happening yeah i mean i would prefer it
if my boss announced that a comic-con
that would be better for me well we're
going to talk about it there's a lot of
there's a lot of holes in phase six that
could get filled with things like armor
wars opening box number three
whoa
box number three okay
one two three this one right here okay
this reminds me there's a little bit of
the old bozo the clown show did you guys
ever watch that yeah you're getting the
balls in the back
okay here we go hey i'm one year younger
than me
two and one i think okay here we go box
number three i have no idea it could be
a scorpion it could be a plush
scorpion reply you have to go all the
way in
[Applause]
you can't that's exactly what i was like
you can't do it me's weak
spaghetti spaghetti held together by
no it's mom's
tape
there's different size noodles and stuff
oh my god
i wanted to cook that
oh
no
oh no that's worse than i thought
he punched he looked he looked like he's
not touching it okay and i just had to
finish the show with the filthy hand
yeah
okay they're our favorite okay the
teleprompter okay so let's go for the
man
uh okay well uh
at that rate uh
they're almost
joke is they're all spaghetti my secret
is i'm always spaghetti okay
i didn't realize why we have to punch
all the way to the bottom ah give him
five yeah you know what
kevin feige mentioned
at comic-con uh that for phases uh five
and six the studio is in a slightly
different rhythm now cool man that's
something we talked a little bit about
on saturday not my tempo more or more
not my tempo um he kind of credited
disney plus with helping them do more
projects in fewer years yeah we pointed
out phase five and six are pretty short
windows of time with a whole bunch of
projects in them right um in fact the
duration right like only the end of
phase six is at the end of 2025 so the
whole thing two phases in about three
years right which is wow that's
squeezing in a lot of content yeah yeah
yeah i'm ready moving on a real clip um
shanghai director and this is the big
news we were teasing earlier the big
director news shanxi director destin
daniel [ __ ]
will be directing the kang dynasty in
phase six the first of the two avengers
movies no word on secret wars yeah but
he's gonna get to direct the kang
dynasty interesting big team-up movie
that's another thing uh uh feige had
said in that interview was that like you
know these uh these phases do kind of
end with big team-up movies but not
always that's
that's not always the case but
um uh ant-man and quantomania he kind of
identified as like a big team up movie
yes kind of like looped it in with these
avenger ones and he even said like you
know multiverse of madness had some
team-up qualities right a lot of people
showed up from different properties as
opposed to like phase one phase two
where it was like it's kind of thor by
himself where it's tony stark by himself
uh but now when you got wanda showing up
in multiverse of madness we don't know
who's showing up in quantum mania we can
speculate about that later he kind of
hinted that wakanda forever even would
feel more like a team up movie right
yeah yeah so exciting stuff but let's
keep talking about phase six while we're
at it folks you know we saw that full
breakdown from kevin feige at comic con
regarding phase five but phase six was
pretty pretty much empty mostly blank do
we have
uh yeah this is what grade six looked
like uh they showed us you know uh
fantastic four and these two avengers
movies but not much else did they just
did they make those logos bigger to take
up more space they definitely fill that
balloon
pop up pump up the logos we can afford
it uh and then they were like wait we'll
show them at d23 but we can't wait for
d23 that's too far away so it said we're
gonna do what we love to do best on this
channel and that's speculate we're gonna
talk about these blank spots in phase
six and try to prognosticate about what
titles will fill in these spots what do
we what do we think is going to happen
in there what do you guys in the chat
think is going to come out
so we have like a few spots
uh open still in phase six right they
showed us
go to the big board fantastic four and
these two avengers but there's two other
movies or these could be tv shows in
fall of 2024 two and winter of 2024 two
in spring 2025 and then two in summer
of 2025. so what do you guys think some
of these things might be i have a i have
a pick for something okay go first i
think might come in it might be fun they
love to put something in between the two
close
avengers movies right we had uh ant-man
and the wasp and and captain marvel in
there i think we could get a little loki
season three whoa
somewhere in this like in between
because if there's so much ken going on
and loki is our introduction to the idea
of king it's he who remains yeah but he
is a king
i think there could be a season three of
loki somewhere in there now we know
we're getting loki season two this
summer
give him two more years and we gotta you
think it'll be treated kind of how uh
black widow was or do you think it will
have to be i think it'll have a lot to
do with you and not be like a jump
backwards yeah like okay black widow or
captain marvel yeah
okay
can i tell you why you're wrong yeah
yeah i think you can pretend
here's why you're wrong right loki we
know
we anticipate season two still gonna be
a lot of kang stuff right maybe so maybe
season three also it's tough to deal
with time travel timelines all this kind
of stuff so like why would they tell a
similar story to the two films in
between the two films i mean they gotta
fill it in here hear me out just like
infinity war ends boom picks up
immediately at the beginning of end game
the two films that come in between you
actually don't need to watch to
understand that much more they they do
help contribute to the story so i don't
think they want to release a series that
appreciably contributes to this
storyline they want this to feel like a
five and a half hour movie or whatever
but i mean i i do think loki season
three but what if i just put it
here okay huh okay a little earlier ah
earlier tommy do you have thoughts i
like that but you know what goes great
if i may come over what goes great as a
summer movie
what gives everybody enough time to
recover
what always fits in in these phases it
does it defies phases it moves beyond
phases
it lives without phases it goes through
phases
that's the simple
spider-man
oh yeah it's a spider-man 4 everyone you
want to see him holland to break yeah
does this get our our spider boy back to
the avengers somehow he has to show up
in secret wars that's right yeah why not
explain why he's there
yeah how he gets that
multitudes of spider-man maybe we even
get a uh ken dynasty push credit
with a peter parker or something like
900 100 leading into a i i like that
movement that's very strong i don't feel
so good um now i want to throw out
another one here again often speculated
about big mystery why we didn't get this
in any of the announcements and i think
it's got to come early
i think we're getting mutants
fantastic before it has to come after
i was looking at their little chart like
this this they kind of showed this
before
okay fantastic for this little spot
maybe maybe after maybe i think you're
right maybe maybe this introduces yes
maybe we get a post-credit scene or
something like that and then here but
even i wonder if even winter is far
enough along maybe it could even be here
we tease them we get a trailer around
here and then the full movie maybe there
yeah yes anna flores i like that
spider-man 4 they can introduce miles
morales and he can be in secret wars i
love it i like it now i i
i'm gonna throw out there kevin feige
mentioned he's reiterated this in the
past but he mentioned an interview after
comic con right that like they think of
like marvel properties at like three
different levels there's like the street
level with daredevil hawkeye echo things
like that there's kind of the the um
supernatural
level that they're starting to explore
with properties like
oh yeah
100
fantastic four then the bottom could
just be following like the scarlet witch
kind of storyline so it could be oh
speak of the devil now jess do you want
to go so far as to place a scarlet witch
solo film do you think we might get one
in this phase i honestly if it did come
it would come
probably spring 2025 between the mutants
and spiderman wow
because she if she shows up she would
probably be showing up in kang dynasty
but i think the mutants and hers should
kind of stay close because if we're
seeing different timelines there's the
newton's film we got to see it be a
i mean this was an angry scarlet witch
stand so don't come at me
could the mutants film
be also kind of like the way captain
america civil war was a captain america
film but it was like an avengers
be heavily featured in the mutants once
again uh you know i know that people
wanted to have her own movie but i just
wonder at this point
well
the main story we're kind of getting to
a space where like
most of these characters are not getting
true solutions unless it's an origin
speaking of origins now i'm just going
to mention this because i think we've
all decided this character might not be
getting anything in phase six right and
that's shanghai okay
he's just to be featured in every other
movie yes he's probably going to
certainly show up in these two maybe in
some other property but that director is
already committed to this movie and he's
committed to wonder man and and a wonder
man series now let's talk about that now
it's it's really hard to direct two huge
marvel movies yeah that are going to
come out in the same kind of 18 month
but do you think
you could direct and kind of executive
produce a disney plus series and a big
movie do you think we could see wonder
man in this yeah i mean it's tough i
don't know what wonder man is gonna be i
don't think she's gonna be like a more
comedic
less serious
kind of show interesting and and what
they're kind of teasing she hopes that i
was gonna say it but it'll have a lot to
do with how she hulk is because
i want to see what yeah what's the other
okay well another sequel to a phase uh
four film
eternals two actually
in between there is a tiny there's a
tiny waste basket underneath the white
how
will be so much fun all the expositions
you're right you're right party time
you're right i'm just being a snotty dog
on the cob in the chat for harry styles
yeah come on corn cob's fairy
now we were just talking about it do we
see armor wars because he was saying
like armor is still happening yes maybe
here because in theory they're working
on it already and maybe this is still
fall 2024 so it could come after army
our army armor wars oh you're staying
from midnight today well i just think of
midnight
do you think are you thinking midnight
suns is a film or a series i think i'm
a series ooh okay disney plus okay let's
throw something radical move scarlet
witch film to fall of 2024. oh oh
elizabeth olsen is excited to play the
character again why make her wait
yeah why make her wait we also have a
doctor strange three yes if we think
they try and pump that up within phase
six
or or do we not see doctor strange again
until well and reward and maybe assume
he's gonna play a pr prominent role in
these films
clumber match is going to want to come
back i'm being annoying
wait what is this one
i agree with the chat the midnight suns
would be in fall just because it's gary
yes um but harry it's scary
but no i think we could keep it there
for now because i agree with tommy
scarlett which is elizabeth welcome
sooner and another property so kev feige
in a kind of red carpet interview after
comic con
the two
fox properties he named did not name the
x-men but he named
fantastic four which is announced
and deadpool oh oh three which is not
yet announced that could go here right
take midnight sun's output deadpool
three there is very chance we know
they're writing it right yeah i was
gonna say is it if this is this is
something again please don't come for me
if i'm saying something's foolish
is there a chance that deadpool exists
outside of the phases
the deadpool 3 is a movie that is made
by marvel studios
but it's not it does
does not need to be canon with anything
else well yeah he just does his own
thing and then that character can be
called in for secret wars
you know what i mean like i don't know
i don't know if he gets his own pick on
the board because he's defies all i'm
just going to throw out some other
properties that that could show up
there's a rumored a koi
uh spin-off series yeah miss marvel two
not to be confused with the marvels some
people consider miss marvel too but this
is a solo film that might be a little
bit later the long rumored
nova project
this could be you know if the upcoming
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is kind of
the end this could be a way of kind of
rebooting that kind of uh
wouldn't probably come until 2025. yes
yeah i think you're right again they're
you know they're already playing in
phase seven okay and they've already got
some things marked out and then i'll
just say the other long rumored thing
kevin feige he was asked about this
refused to elaborate yeah young young
avengers project i almost feel like
young avengers might be folded into the
avengers movies like they're going yes
like they're going to save the day at
the end of the kang dynasty like they
don't need to be they don't need to be
separated just it'll be they'll be you
know it'll be stature and um right
williams will be fighting alongside
doctor strange and
hawkeye and whoever else yeah so out of
all these which ones do you think we're
not doing
oh we still have more we sell more i
mean these are
all the options okay well here let's
remove one at a time you think is not
going to happen in phase six
two we feel pretty confident won't
happen eternal's two tommy's burying it
okay
burying it i just don't know where else
they're gonna bring in
the harry styles i guess they could
bring them in
that would bring in and then
the koi series is definitely not
happening okay fair and maybe maybe
phase six will have some kind of black
panther property in it whether it's this
series whether it's a black panther
three something like that wasn't there
a like a
some sort of teaser announcement for a
wakanda series or is that always yes
well ryan coogler's been working on that
yeah we've got no other information i
think that's kind of the same thing
there
they already have an animated series but
no one talks about it it's a great
series i love it um i'm going to say
just because we're getting the marvels
coming up next year we might take a
couple years off of miss marvel stories
okay
anything else
i would say deadpool three guaranteed in
this phase it's i'm saying that's a lock
i'm saying i don't know if midnight sons
is gonna
i wanted to you don't know how bad i
want it but i just don't know if it's 20
24
because there's so many people in the
midnight sense that we haven't even seen
yet and i don't think we're going to see
this year
who's your pick for ghost rider oh god
someone was talking about someone asked
and i can't remember who it was online
and i was like i'd be okay with that um
i mean i do love the ryan gosling has
been openly campaigning for it and i
love him but who's the um ghost writer
has of course been portrayed by a couple
characters is it robbie reyes is that
the um the east l.a like a latino
how much i hate [ __ ] like okay
not like me no tentative
uh bucket punch two two two i mean it's
gotta be spaghetti
it's a gift oh
you almost punched right
we've got two buckets left one of the
buckets was gross one of the buckets is
very nice wait what's in that pug mug
wait a second
um the the projects i feel strongest
about i do feel deadpool three
definitely gonna happen
uh i do feel like armor wars they've
already announced it i bet it's gonna
happen
one of our super chatters lamar 1986
suggesting a doctor doom movie in
between the two big finales whoa setting
up phase seven i mean they've never made
a movie that's from the perspective of a
villain oh yeah which would be very
interesting yeah uh to have the villain
be the protagonist of the movie uh would
be an interesting way to take it
um also you know people in the chat
calling for like a young avengers movie
where is that
uh uh freight girls you know scarlet
witch house of m we all want a house of
m story that's right uh here for the
cookie center and uh super chat miles
morales versus peter parker and secret
wars but they just decide to hug it out
the people
spidey boys can't fight yeah
ooh yeah do we see
do we get my live-action miles more
alice for secret wars i don't think so
they better do it
i think it was that they brought they
even brought jessica drew in so i think
they can just bring in like all the
spiderman right into the spider or
across the spider verse is gonna be very
interesting to see what they do with
that after all of this multiverse stuff
after marvel being like animation could
cross over to live action i would say
the one thing going against a miles
morales prominently featured in an
avengers movie
sony well but i bet sony wants
well somebody wants to see the value i
don't think marvel they're just holding
on to it right because that's a money
maker dude that's a money maker right
now marvel doesn't want to help them
have mult uh more billion dollar
franchises you know we begged for
answers we begged for where is this all
headed we begged we begged and begged
for more info and now i feel more
fragmented than ever which is why i want
to thank our sponsors and our friends at
betterhelp for sponsoring the break room
this week thank you yes and i saw it
bobby i see you she's trying to get in
there again bobby we'll get here
multiple folks on the new rockstar staff
have used better health in the past and
i'm currently using it right now okay
we're big fans of taking care of our
mental well-being i have neglected it
for a long time and i go in and out of
therapy and now i said no mouse
thomas
must get this thing right better help
online therapy will assess your needs
and can match you with your own licensed
professional therapist in less than 48
hours i cannot
express this enough it is an easy
process you go on the computer you over
share as much as you want for me i was
getting into like you know what kind of
sneezes i've been having before the
algorithm said that's enough but and
then they match you with somebody and
you set an appointment and it's all on
your terms they ask that the first
appointment should be maybe on over
video but after that it can be texting
it can be emails you can do more video
sessions it's if i can pull this off by
myself without having my little bitty
hand held by a true adult any which i
will take any of you can do it so check
out
all the testimonials they have on their
website of real users sharing their
experience with better health therapists
and this is the part that is actually
pretty nice
they have a special offer for our
breakers our roomies our trash bags get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
slash break room that's 10 percent off
your first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com don't forget to use our
magical word okay you use break room or
i break you you know what i bring oh
okay maybe talk about that with your
therapist okay i hug you i hug you yes i
hug you
now before what no no go
i would say can i open it yeah that's
what we're doing oh okay our third uh
our third mystery box yeah
we want to thank bobby for uh really
financing at two of these openings
number four
ready spaghetti
look at her face
i got the gift that
keeps in hindsight the spaghetti was
yeah
holy cow what's the last one keys to a
lamborghini oh my god why only three oh
that's right i can't drink on the show
i'm also not gonna these are for me i
didn't say i was sharing it
one for every mile home she's gotta
drive um
taking it to all of our super chat i'm
so happy this is the best gift i could
have ever gotten we also ran a couple
polls with the chat we should shout out
uh do you think kang will be a better
villain than thanos 81 if you said yes
whoa
i think that's mainly we always want the
villains to get better and better and
you know what i'd like to think we have
an optimistic audience yeah i was gonna
say that would have been really sad if
the answer was like hell no hell no
this thing tweaked and now they got 18
more movies coming out what's your
favorite marvel face so far good lord
mike marino pushes us over the edge oh
my god we're opening that fourth
uh and then when do you think we'll see
armor wars 51 said face it's six
after phase five
oh still a couple people think it might
get snuck into phase five yeah
yeah we think they've announced
everything for phase five there were no
empty slots uh but they could always
throw something else in there iron iron
hearts pay five yes okay
that's confirmed that's on that's on the
graph you're the last one to open the
box well now i'm uh afraid to open okay
there's only one bucket left this is the
last bucket thing can i have the
spaghetti bucket is that a program dad
must eat the spaghetti the spaghetti
must be consumed
[Music]
speaking of across the spider verse
is
[Applause]
oh my god that's a good so all of us got
pretty good ones except wow
i'm gonna find something in my car to
give to zach as a gift no and and i will
commit to taking at least one bite of
the spaghetti of 500. we don't know how
old that spaghetti is that's right uh we
don't even know if it's edible uh it was
made for human consumption speaking of
things made for human consumption tommy
yeah it's time but we do i don't know
you guys feel like
sometimes i feel like i don't know do we
need to do
mandatory fun
it's the segment
so proper
we even do it when john goes to the dog
doctor
hit it again
that's true our health insurance does
not let us see people doing it that's
right it's the segment so wild we do it
well john's dog can't no longer give
birth to a child or a pregnant dog
because he's been neutered again
it's the segment so saucy that we do it
even without our bossy because philip's
not here either hit it again
alright now they're asking you keep the
outfit on i feel like a fortnight
character
am i chagging you also a little bit was
it vega
now we know that avengers kang dynasty
will be directed by shang shi's destin
daniel [ __ ]
which will uh which leads avengers
secret wars is the remaining
directorless avengers film the russo
brothers have expressed interest in
directing avengers secret wars but kevin
feige says
not so
fast why don't you go back and reboot
one of your little cute sitcoms
we're not doing it
i don't want it so we're gonna do our
best the son of the conflict here on
break room debate club that's right
we're taking it back to high school a
time where i kept my virginity every
single night
all right
zach and i will be team feige while
jessica and spider-man 2099 will be
repping the russos we'll have two rounds
uh the first round we'll each be arguing
our case and then we'll have a brief
rebuttal round and then of course the
chat
will vote correctly on zach and i uh and
our possession that's uh intimidating
the witness you and spaghetti let's flip
water
to see who gets to go first wait wings
or snout uh
we'll take snow
we are going to be presenting the
argument why if if this is the rooster
brothers want to do it fikey doesn't
want them to do it that's right we're
presenting the feige side of the
argument that's right here right why we
should all trust our lord and savior mr
kevin ex feige um
here's here's what we want to say okay
uh tommy uh feel free to jump in but
the russo brothers are um they're hand
holders that's right okay maybe they can
they're they're not necessarily
visionaries anybody watch gray man over
the weekend new netflix film oh it's
great it's it is it's a lot of fun ryan
gosling's wonderful in it but is any did
that movie change anybody's life no did
anybody did anybody cry or cheer in that
movie like they did at avengers end game
absolutely not let me give you my review
gray man it was okay man
nobody likes a stale donut is what i'm
saying and the russos have been in the
box
at the disney cafe for going on a decade
they've been struck it out they've been
there they've done that they're old wood
at this point okay look at all the
directing decisions
look at all the direct decisions have
been made going forward young up and
coming directors even dustin destin
dustin daniel [ __ ] i can't say
anything today right who's going to be
directing the first of the avengers
films he does not have a super long
uh filmography okay he did do shanghi
that was his first big movie and then he
did some tiny indies before that short
term 12 a couple other little things
feige knows what he's doing he takes up
and covered hungry yeah hungry he's
gonna get their teeth into the source
material and then put it all on the
screen yes a visual painting even the
russos when they got uh
captain america captain america
the uh
soldier uh or was it civil war
i don't know
okay here's the deal
you want to watch community played out
by the avengers the russo's direct you
want to watch an amazing film with fight
choreography that'll blow your balls
through the back your throat go with
feige's plan okay that's right we got to
trust him he's been shepherding this
whole thing yeah he was one that
delivered us
in game really shepherding all these
phases yeah sure the russo brothers name
was on it but this is a big
this is a big thing and we need a big
man to deliver it a big man in a ball
cap and i heard a rumor that the ruse
hoes are both
uh
robots okay okay
that's what i heard you know who else is
a great robot vision yeah uh yeah so
your argument doesn't stand
he's actually a what's he called an
adaptoid or something like that or he's
not it's a synthesizer synthesized
that's it you don't even know you don't
even know well thanks for your help man
either way
all right me and brandon over here we
wrote our stuff down yeah
arrested development community
the first man flight
what do these all have in common
brothers brothers the russo brothers
brothers infinity war end game a
delicate film you know we all loved it
we loved it it was beautiful uh i need
to be reassured that secret wars is
gonna be the same you know secret wars
is been a long time in the making it
started in the 80s we got the 2015 run
and who are the two biggest fans that
are directors that have openly come out
and said this was our childhood comic
book
the russo brothers
the russo brothers would love to do this
film and you know what's better you know
it's better than two
three three three there's a third there
is another
if they all work together you think they
can't make a masterpiece together yeah
you guys
it's let them have their white whale
let them let them captain ahab yeah let
them do it let them get what they want
yeah because they gave us two great
marvel cinematic pieces and i think they
would just go above and beyond for
secret wars which is something we all
want to see
okay really good well you can't clap for
yourself
we still have a closer right well you
get to you get your butt all right oh i
thought you both talking where the same
okay now
manson
not a brother
hang on manson gambino crime
fratelli those are all families that are
murderers menendez menendez bosti
marathon bombing yeah
my gosh these are brothers and families
that do nothing but kill
feige what is it what does feige mean
create feige means create it means
marvel it means create marvel
you
don't look it up
i i just wanna this is this is my
rebuttal okay um
the russo brothers the russo brothers
and their unknown third sister yeah
gonna be in their mid to late 70s by the
time this film comes out that's that's
confirmed they're both there is another
i don't know they're i'm sorry they're
going to be close to 90.
too old to make what will be the biggest
movie of all time joe russo
is 104 years old that's right minimum
his brother anthony
is an octogenarian
missing one kidney another one i heard
going down the toilet soon they they
both did stand in work for old man cap
during endgame that's confirmed okay do
you know what else i heard
no one knows where they were on january
6th
oh my god
oh wow okay show us the text messages
show us the text messages tommy we also
don't know where you were
[Applause]
arguments from the two gentlemen across
from me yeah but what i haven't heard
from this
pro-frankie crowd is an answer
you put up no other names to direct this
great film scorsese
you trust kevin feige's plan as much as
you say you do yeah then you should
trust the plan he already has and that's
picking great directors like the russo
brothers thank you you compared the gray
man you compared it like was it an end
game
the russo brothers directed in game
they can direct the secret wars 21
bridges i'd cross them all to watch the
russos
the gray man why i'd be rainbow colored
happy to see the russo brothers i
haven't watched the great man hi jerry i
have not seen cherry either but i have
the options to okay
uh the russo brothers are the best ones
to do this
you know what you do with old wood you
make beautiful furniture out of it oh
and that's what secret words reduce
reusable recyclables
by the russo brothers will do okay there
there are the two arguments uh pro feige
pro russo i'm sure everybody watching
has been swayed one way or the other by
these sound and cogent arguments filled
with facts
just remember one man put his hand in
spaghetti
and when we don't like the facts we make
new facts
russo brothers confirmed to have
said arsenic oh my god
stop musso sent anthrax over the mail
uh okay while we wait for that paul in
the chat everybody to pick sides
um
everyone take his fight a fight that
does not exist and it's only made up for
our enjoyment again we want to thank
everybody that uh donated super chats
today to help us uh punch holes in four
of these buckets revealing fun
five now really i know in hindsight we
should add like 14 buckets uh next time
thank you uh a couple other quick super
chats we want to call out uh stacy c you
tell them jess i assume i was just in
case
basically everything just got a mic
dropped
i agree with um yuka prieta saying what
if k what if feige was kevin mcallister
he they are they're the same person they
look exactly the same
you think feige is the anthropomorphic
representation of a fictional character
it's come to life he's building a house
i think he's based off buses girlfriend
woof
who ate all the cheese pizza
you know i could only eat cheese pizza
uh also a shout out i think we did we
did call out mike farino thank you cal
thank you for your super chat td jones
uh
frequent audience member we appreciate
you td saying what if those avengers
movies are actually young avengers
movies uh could be i mean that is honest
to god it could be where it is i mean
the immunes are just the young young
i'm so sorry no no totally but i think
by the time we get to kang dynasty in
secret wars right well there's obviously
no tony stark there's no um
chris evans captain america uh there's
no natasha maybe no um several other
existing maybe ruffalo's done by then
maybe hemsworth we don't know so maybe
you have to fill those ranks with a lot
of these young avengers right and
they're just regular avengers but
they're young you know dobson i would
never accuse you of this but that poll
ended so quickly i don't think we
actually got everyone involved
yeah you know what i think a lot of
people were still voting people were
having a tough time understanding you're
afraid you're afraid stay in line you're
crazy confused
of this election yeah we're gonna stop
to
steal stop the camera we do not accept
the results of this malicious poll
wow well my our uh buddy mike ferrino
there in the chat saying russo started
coven so that no movie ever passes end
game holds water whoa
there's no evidence of that oh there's
no evidence that they didn't
so are you in this weird fixation
pangolin don't know i'm not doing it
oh my god it's called bad debating
one-on-one let me tell you you guys are
the kings of it what about ism
what
is our next discussion you might be
asking and it's my discussion which is
what is king's plan now that we know
that we have the kang dynasty coming and
secret wars uh it seems like clearly
king is going to be the biggest part of
this all so
how do we get from loki to quantum mania
to kang dynasty and secret wars what is
he doing what is he up to he did say oh
sorry no no no sorry i was going to say
he did say in the trailer for quantum
male 1 guanamalaia quantum mechanics
meaning
they said you're an avenger have i
killed you before and then he goes on to
say uh there will be conquering yes
how do we think we got here so here's
what i this is my thought i feel like
this is
quantum mania is kind of being set up
more like a captain america sequel than
a thor sequel ragnarok we got kind of a
standalone thor movie until the
post-credits scene when the purple light
flashes on the asgardians and we see the
thanos is about to
board and that's setting up uh infinity
war it feels like they're trying to push
quantum mania as like this is the most
important ant-man film that there has
been so far this is this is ant-man and
the wasp and any new characters that are
coming in from that storyline but
there's also going to be this is mcu
ramifications from title card to good
bytel cards
okay well it's also interesting that
can't you know with thanos he was always
post credits post credits barely got to
know him and then infinity war we
finally are introduced and we go through
the whole thing for those two movies
this is like they've introduced he who
remains who is a king and now we're
going to have
king as the main villain and i just
realized you have the cape around your
hair it's the best way
but he's going to be a major villain so
it is weird to have like this event
happen early 2024 and not get paid off
until kang dynasty yeah there's no way
kang's in every project in between those
two well the ripple effects might be
there and it would be interesting if
most of phase six is dealing with rmcu
in shambles yeah and there was instead
of like with endgame just the first half
is the mcu in shambles right the first
half of that film what if this whole
year is just like all of these heroes
dealing with the destruction of the mcu
the wrap up being tang dynasty and
secret wars where we find a new home to
put everybody basically 100 that's kind
of a resolution
it's exactly 12 months right from
fantastic four to uh secret wars right
like i love that you pick like it's that
season it's a year of just like the
season of chaos and whatever
thinking that we might need to reorder
some of our picks for uh going to come
in phase six but i like that logic
because there's not like kang's in every
movie no no it's gonna be different well
kind of in the same way a lot of the
early appearances of thanos right he was
just popping into various credit scenes
it's kind of a tenuous connection he
wasn't playing a prominent role here's
what i'm gonna say i'm gonna throw out
there i do think in one of these some of
these early kang appearances maybe it's
quantum mania um maybe it's loki season
two we need to see kang get some big w's
oh he's going too i think he's going to
get an even quantum mania i think it's
going to be nothing but dubs up until
like right before kang dynasty or right
before secret war or something it it's
going to go down clearly and then he's
going to go boom well that's the nice
thing is like you can kill a king but
it's like that wasn't the best one
there's another one ah
somehow kang has returned i just don't
know it get a very slippery slope of
pissing me off of like
we killed the strongest one but then
there's this lift it up
you love the villain
it's your favorite i know i love them do
we think that uh because in secret wars
we doom is a huge part of it do we think
that we are even setting up for doom to
show up in secret wars or be the big bad
of secret wars are we just setting up
for kane i mean you gotta have doom and
fantastic four yeah he's gotta at least
get teased watch him be the before he's
doomed in
secret oh he's nice
nice he's gonna be on the game dynasty
turns well and here's what i'll say both
pro and khan for doom being in fantastic
four both the previous film iterations
of fantasy four have had a doctor right
right so maybe they just want to take a
break from that it's why you don't have
to have um
you know norman osborne
in the uh most recent tom holland
spider-man movies we've seen two
different versions of him we can take a
break from him maybe they take a break
there and and we can wait and see a
different doctor doom later maybe we
start with a different fantastic four
villain yeah what if he's it's dr doom
but he's not a medical doctor he's like
a doctor of sociology he's like doctor
professor yeah he's a true politician i
also think that with secret wars there
was like a right a good and a bad side
but i think in the movie secret wars
there's gonna be like seven teams it's
gonna be like because in civil war even
the heroes couldn't fight together like
they split up so there's gonna be a lot
of people split up and i could see still
like kang running one half of like evil
people and doom
doom um running the other half my
biggest part is like hey where does
galactus come in and all that and then
and on top of that uh is white vision
going to be on the good or bad side
my sources are telling me that m night
shyamalan is in talks to direct secret
wars
there's one thing you know that new wood
gonna be just gonna end in a twist oh my
god and i'll tell you right now i will
be the only person that doesn't
understand that twist i never catch the
twist in the night shyamalan movies i'm
really gullible they were dead the whole
time i knew bruce willis was dead wait
what do you mean they're not actually in
1850. i do i do love and if they follow
the model set forth by like the thanos
and the infinity saga right like most of
his early appearances he was always like
the the
behind the curtain villain
right ronan was actually the bad guy in
guardians one right loki was doing the
work in
the avengers movie right and thanos was
pulling the strings from behind the
curtain but we didn't really know that
so like they could do that with a lot
modoc could be the main villain in
quantum mania and uh kang is just a
behind the curtain kind of figure that
we barely see as impact felt right uh
michael sykes thank you call vos please
um shoot that's not today's redemption
noted um yeah we're not we're uh we're
not doing that today but we appreciate
you michael sykes maybe tomorrow maybe
that pushes over the top when we try to
give eric voss a call oh yeah we're
gonna organize it but you did say if we
reach 500 it'll take a bite of that
spaghetti okay
i'll i'll uh i'll begin my prep zach eat
the spaghetti
on his shirt already this week tom
spaghetti a couple other super chatters
today allison crooks saying thoughts
that's not enough
whoa that's how the dfdc drone is
looking for enhanced individuals being a
sentinel precursor absolutely awesome oh
my god he's a caveman that was two week
old spaghetti
you just guilted me eating more
yeah
but then you're aghast then i did it oh
my god wow
healthy filthy filthy boy
is that marinara or is that more of a go
on and take another bite to let us know
is that an alfredo sauce
experience i've been told that vos has
been legally contracted to not appear on
con uh but we're gonna do what we can
because you know eric and i are old
friends
if if eric ross did have a presence in
tomicon would it be more like the dc
panel or the marvel panel it would be a
marvel panel oh oh an epic a game
changer it would be a lot of
announcements it would be a lot of
excitement and uh you don't have to do
any more honey uh
he's actually kind of liking it mateen
leandro uh super chat what if the movies
in between are about rahmatet and that
is the first mutant movie hello from
brazil hello to brazil
uh i like the idea of jumping way back
in time and seeing like rahmatut and
what was happening then they obviously
have set that up on moon night that
rahmat existed
that would be very cool to see what do
you think the odds are you you i think
either brandon or jessica pointed out
earlier we could see a kang die in one
of these movies but it doesn't matter
because there's so many different things
on top of that on secret wars you can
bring literally anyone back so that's
why i said durian i think on saturday i
was like don't if someone does die in
phase five and six it's like you can
probably get a different version of them
in secret i guess that's
because those 89 year old russo brothers
evidently are going to have keys to the
kingdom one more time let's see the
birth certificate mike
i don't believe they're americans get
them out of here mike milkey said it a
super chat saying i think kang dynasty
and secret wars will be the multiversal
war miss minutes told loki about at the
tva
now a lot of what miss minutes said at
the tva was propaganda
set forth by he who remains but there
probably is a multiversal war going on
out there my favorite thing is them all
appearing randomly in secret wars and
being like what and then it's miss
minutes hi there like i'd be like
straight healthy
uh fluffy muffin sending in a super jet
asking if the two avengers films are
linked why not have daniel justin
crenton direct both of them i mean that
makes sense it makes more sense because
it's going to be so hard for the
director for that first one to pick up
or the second one to pick up where the
first one left off might as well just ha
because that's what uh taika watiti did
for thor 11 thunder to uh james gunn
right then he was like we put the goats
in there just to mess with him because
he has to pick up where i left off
so
it would make more sense to at least
have him be like very heavily involved
uh i think i want to counterpoint i
think we all learned from the last star
wars prequel or sequels that when you
mix up directors
it adds a spicy emotional flair that
everybody's a big fan of you don't want
to have a through line or an idea what
you want to do you want to do you want
to go like this this is what you want to
do
it would just be in brooklyn
tim burton to direct oh god oh oh
musical about the avengers
oh secret wars
for the secret core
they live in dungeons frolicking
spider-man
superman
super duper pooper scooper man johnny
depp
he's giving away for free yet
i would see tim burton fighting superman
into the mcu and being like i don't know
these superheroes i actually don't give
a [ __ ] about any of these people this is
uh
get in there if you if you like musical
renditions of uh fake director film
combos yeah comic-con
you're going to see the 75 minute
version of
us
we just signed black jack the uh black
jack black impersonator the black jack
jack black
oh
a sentient duck that sells insurance and
is batman yeah and as a drinking person
don't forget to join our discord uh we
do have a discord here at new rockstars
and over on the district you can submit
like your favorite clip from the break
room we're gonna start showing a clip of
the week every friday you know um ben
affleck you know his favorite
collaborator is who's that jerry
duckheimer
you know first i was mad we circled back
that joke was foul
4pm pacific okay that's that's when
these jokes really flow run don't flock
to tomicon also on our discord brian
gosling
his name he's yeah a duck bug too easy
that's too easy
tom honks
it's more goose than duck i would say
more boost than duck
[Applause]
you can send in voicemails from trying
to start doing voicemails on the show
stop i need to use the bathroom let's go
finish it close your crane
it's a bird uh uh also send in your
voicemails you can ask questions about
what we think about marvel dc you ask us
personal questions questions about
watchmen actress mallard ackermann
i'm so angry is there any other stuff
for them
can you scroll down on the spaghetti
all right
but yes make sure to tune in for tomicon
on friday this week uh and yeah check
out our discord submit your favorite
clips send us voicemails do all that fun
stuff uh hey and make sure you have a
great rest of your tuesday thanks for
watching everybody wing crosby
[Music]